- All right y'all we're
gonna finish things up
with one last story
I'm hoping you'll enjoy as much as I do.
This is what I'm liking.
(Upbeat music)
It's remarkable how little
of a filter kids have
before they speak.
Case in point, check out
this third grade teacher
instructing her students
on the basics of title abbreviations.
- Mrs.
So not to be confused with,
Mrs. is when someone's married
but I use Ms. because Ms. can be either/or
you could say the person's not married or-
- [Child 2] Why you not a Mrs?
- You know I'm not married.
- [Child 1] Oh.
- [Several Students] Oh.
- [Child 2] Why you have
to do her like that?
You know her situation.
- [Child 3] Miss Jasmine,
you will never be one.
- [Child 2] Okay. First of all,
I'm not even gonna check you right now,
because I know Ms. Evans
gonna make you read a book-
- [Child 1] Read a book!
- [Child 2] So you might
want to check yourself, sir.
- (laughing) Oh, my God.
- I don't know what's funnier,
The fact that they were all like "Ooh"
or how defensive the kids were for her.
It was amazing.
Probably why that video has racked up
more than 2 million views on TikTok.
Luckily the teacher,
Jasmine, has a good sense
of humor about the whole thing.
And we have her on the
line right now watching
on NBC5, Dallas Fort Worth.
What's up Jasmine?
- [Crowd] Ooh! (applauding).
- Hello, Kelly.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Oh my
God, are your students
always that sassy?
- Yes.
- (laughing)
- They're, I have a big,
full of personality,
bunch of students.
I know that they're gonna go far in life,
because they have a
lot to offer the world.
And, I started recording my lessons
to share with their parents.
And I get a mixture
between the parents saying,
"oh my gosh, is that my kid?"
and "oh, that's my kid!"
And so, from the parents
my own friends and family
not believing me,
it's nice to see that the
world can see what I deal with,
what I've been dealing with,
and my experiences for the
past five years as a teacher.
- Oh my gosh. I know.
God bless you first of all.
Being a teacher, the patience
of Job is what y'all have.
So, they all really reacted
to you not being married.
So do you think they really cared?
Because there were kids in
there that got mad for you.
- No, I think it's,
we have a way of having
little playful banter
between our lessons
and I don't think they.
They have a lot of love for me and
we can have those interactions and
I think at the end of
the day, I love the kids.
I love that.
I know that they're learning.
We have those times where I can
humanize myself as a teacher
and at the end of the day,
they feel comfortable with me.
They come to me and they tell me
probably more than they should,
but I like having that
line of of communication
open with them. They trust me, you know.
- And that's awesome.
That's amazing that kids have that.
My kids have been fortunate
to have amazing teachers
and I did as well.
Thank you so much, Jasmine.
I'm liking your post right now, right?
- [Audience] (whooping and applauding)
- And that's not all.
That's actually not all.
Our season-long partner
Pilot Pen, makers of G2,
the go-to pen of the Kelly Clarkson show,
they want to honor ultimate
overachievers just like you.
So they're gonna be writing you a check
for a thousand dollars.
How does that sound?
- [Audience] (Whooping and applauding)
- Oh my!
- [Kelly Clarkson] I love it!
- Thank you.
Absolutely.
Well, God bless you.
Thank you so much for being an educator.
We appreciate you.
Thank you so much.